let's say I have a cliff let's make this
cliff I don't know miss say it's 50
meters high 50 meters and on this cliff
I have a car and this car is not just
sitting on the cliff it's driving off of
it a very dramatic problem so let's see
if this car here and it's driving off of
this cliff at five meters per second
five meters per second and I want to
know what is the path of this car as it
falls off of the cliff so let's set up a
little coordinate axes here say that I
get my y-axis let's say that this is the
y-axis right there and then this will be
my x-axis x-axis so this is y this is X
let's say that this is the point well we
know this is a 50 meter high cliff maybe
y equals zero is sea level so this is
this would be 50 right here and let's
say that this point right here on the
cliff that said X is equal to X is equal
to 10 so this point right here is the
point 10 comma 15 let's say the car is
right at this point right about to drive
off the cliff at time is equal to zero
so this is at time equal to zero time
equal to zero so T for time time is
equal to zero so my question is what
happens to this call car as it drives
off the cliff so this is a bit of a
physics problem and I won't go deep into
the physics and I won't prove some of
the equations and I encourage you to
watch the kinematics videos the
projectile motion videos if you want to
know where the equations come from but
the point here is just to get the
equations and see what the graph looks
like so if I were to know X as a
function of time X is a function of time
let me know suitably vibrant color so X
as a function of time is going to be
what well we're going to assume that
we're on a on a planet that has no air
where in a vacuum so if we start off in
the X direction at 5 meters per second
to the right we
won't be decelerated by air or friction
or anything else Newton's laws of motion
an object in motion stays in motion
unless it's a unless it's unless it's
affected by a net force and there won't
be any net force in the X direction so
it's just going to keep moving to the
right at five meters per second and
position or distance it's just equal to
velocity times time our velocity is five
times time and of course it didn't start
at tot at X is equal to zero right this
is at time equals zero so it started at
X is equal to ten so you want to know
it's kind of X of zero where it started
off so plus ten and this should make be
a little intuitive for you right at time
is equal to zero this term cancels out
we're at X is equal to ten that that
makes sense at time is equal to one we
should be a little bit will be five
meters further out so on and so forth
fair enough
that's X as a function of the parameter
time as you probably realize that this
is a video on parametric equations not
physics so it's nice to early on say the
word parameter parameter parameter and
time tends to be the parameter when
people talk about parametric equations
although it could be anything it could
be radius or or angle or who knows what
else so let's figure out what Y is as a
function of time so why Y as a function
of time it's going to be equal to the
initial Y position or Y of 0 which is 50
where 50 meters up in the air
50 meters up in the air plus the our
initial velocity in the Y direction and
we don't actually have any velocity in
the Y direction the car isn't jumping or
isn't diving it's it's just moving
horizontally to the right and and the
cliff is supporting it so it's not it
has no Y velocity but if you were
curious it would be the Y velocity times
time but since there's no Y velocity
times time at least initially
I'll put nothing there plus the
acceleration of gravity times so times x
squared over 2 we want to figure out the
sign and just just so you know I mean
it's nice to touch on the physics a
little
just so you know where these formulas
come from and you know the motivation
behind why you would even use a
parametric equation gravity goes
downwards in this example and downwards
in this example is in the minus y
direction with y is decreasing and the
the real and you know it's not exact but
you know gravity is normally 9.8 meters
per second squared in most textbooks but
for the sake of simplifying this we'll
say that it's approximately 10 meters
per second squared that's how fast
everything will be accelerated downward
on this planet since it has no where
let's assume it's a planet with a little
bit more mass than Earth and since it's
going downwards this direction is
negative so in our formula up here it's
our initial position we had no velocity
times time so I won't put that there
minus 10 meters per second squared times
T squared over 2 and you can watch the
projectile motion videos to figure out
how I got these these formulas right
there but that's not the point at this
the point of this is to graph what
happens to the cars and learn a little
bit about parametric equations so what
is the path of this car as it falls off
the cliff let's make a table here let's
make a table and I'll do the so x and y
are a function of this third parameter T
so we're going to set T at different
values and we're going to figure out
what x and y are equal to and I'm just
going to arbitrarily pick some T's T is
equal to 0 T is equal to 1 2 & 3 at time
is equal to 0 what is X X of 0 this is 0
X is equal to 10 meters at time is equal
to 1 what is X so this is X of 1 right
if I wanted to write that notation so 5
times 1 is 5 plus 10 is 15 X of 2 5
times 2 plus 10 that's 20 and it makes
sense every second we're getting 5
meters more to the right or X is
increasing by 5 meters so a neck T is
equal to 3 15 plus 10 is 25 easy enough
the Y is a little bit more complicated
and just to simplify this it's the same
thing as 5 right 10 divided by 2 so 50
minus 5t
squared so time is equal to zero this
term cancels out
we just have 50 meters up in the air at
time is equal to 1 1 squared is 1 times
5 is 5 50 minus 5 is 40 or 45 meters in
the air is that right right yeah time
150 right and then at time is equal to 2
2 squared is 4 4 times 5 is 20 50 minus
20 is 30 and then finally at time is
equal to 3 9 SI finally because that's
the last number we picked time is equal
to 3 3 squared is 9 9 times 5 is 45 50
minus 45 is 5 so let's plot these points
so time is equal to 0 that's that's what
we got right there at time is equal to 1
where X is equal to 15 that's roughly
you see this is 5 10 15 let me do all of
them 15 20 25 and then the y-axis let me
label that while we're at it so this is
roughly 10 20 30 40 50 so time is equal
to 0 where 10 50 that's that point right
there at time is equal to 1 where it 15
45 so X is 15 Y is 45 which is right
about there so this is T is equal to 1
at time is equal to 2 or at the at the
coordinate 20 30 so 20 and 30 it's right
about there
so this is at time is equal to 2 and
then at time is equal to 3 we're 25 5 so
we're right there 25 5 time is equal to
3 and if we kept going on at some point
we're going to hit the ground you can
figure out actually set this equal to 0
and you figure out the exact time you
hit the ground actually let's do that if
if this is equal to 0 50 you get T is
equal to the square root of 10 which is
a little over 3 seconds which makes
sense right a little over 3 seconds
we're going to be hitting the ground but
anyway what's the path of this car
what's going to look something like this
it's going to look like this
it starts getting accelerated downwards
and then plunk it hits the ground at
three-point-something seconds now what
was interesting here is that by setting
the parameter not only did we get the
curve right we got this curve which is
kind of half of a parabola half of a
downward shaping parabola and we can
actually eliminate the T and just get
the equation for that parabola and we'll
do that in future videos but what was
interesting by making it a parametric
equation we know the direction of the
car if you just saw this graph without
the car and everything else I drew you
wouldn't know which way the car is
falling but now we know that as T is
increasing we're going in that direction
so we can draw some arrows here so
because it's a parametric equation we
can draw some arrows and then the most
important thing is we know exactly where
the car is at any time T you can
substitute T is equal to 1.25 seconds
and you know exactly where the car is so
you can plot these points and you can
kind of get a sense that as as time goes
on we're getting accelerated downwards
and that's why for every second further
the especially the Y distance gets
further and further apart anyway I just
wanted to give you this example this
wasn't although this was a good physics
problem the intention wasn't to teach
you physics the intention is to give you
the motivation behind why parametric
equations even exist parametric
equations this these two things are
parametric equations we defined x and y
as a function of a third parameter T
instead of defining Y in terms of X or X
in terms of Y like we've done every
other time since then and this is super
useful I mean you could imagine when you
have really hard physics problems where
you want to figure out the
three-dimensional position of something
then you'll have X as a function of T Y
as a function of T Z is a function of T
all sorts of interesting problems come
out of using parametric equations not
just in physics but anyway I thought a
good place to start is the motivation
because the first time I learn
parametric equations like why mess up my
nice and simple world of X's and Y's why
introducing a third parameter T this is
why because you can figure out the path
of things you can figure out the
direction of something as it moves along
a curve and you can figure out the exact
position at any in this case
time